[Musique]
une fois son dit il je t'aime bien et je
te respecte je te respecte beaucoup
mais j'aurai ta peau avant la fin de la
journée
[Musique]
au cercle suivant il s'en fallut de peu
qu'ils ne la trappe à mais le poisson se
redresse encore et c'est le règne a
lentement
tu veux ma mort poisson pensa le lieu
c'est ton droit camarades j'ai jamais
rien avec plus grande et plus nobles
onic plus calme n'est plus beau que toi
allez vas-y tu moi ça m'est égal lequel
de nous deux qui tu vas
[Musique]
à 100 pieds en dessous un espadon était
en train de manger des sardines qui
recouvrait la pointe et la saillie
l'hameçon à l'endroit où celui-ci percer
la tête du petit tour
il a un nez trop long aussi longue d'une
batte de baseball pointu communauté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vieil homme et la mer c'est le premier
livre que j'ai lu sans images quand
j'étais petit j'avais 10 ans et je l'aï
dévoré d'un trait
[Musique]
ce qui est intéressant c'est d'abord
toute cette patience cette humilité qui
est qui est dégagée par le vieil homme
et la transmission à cet enfant qui suit
vous cache t il pleurait et c'est vrai
que c'est assez un bouc l'unc et moi
j'étais petit et je lisais ça je voulais
être comme le petit
[Musique]
pourquoi après tout la littérature ne
donnerait-elle pas naissance à une
vocation de pêcheurs
hemingway le vieil homme qui lutte à
mort avec un espadon et depuis l'âge de
6 ans
jacques alba n'a eu de cesse de prendre
la mer
aujourd'hui il tente une nouvelle
aventure départ de l'île de la réunion
direction sud ouest
jacques a lâché les commandes pour
devenir armateurs sa nouvelle folie
s'appelle à la longue un bateau de 34
mètres armé spécialement pour traquer
l'espadon pour pouvoir dénicher partout
dans l'océan indien
les hommes d'équipage n'ont pas trop des
deux jours de route pour fourbir la
palangre appelé aussi longue line une
ligne flottante qui sera posé à
l'arrière du bateau à la longue à entame
seulement sa deuxième campagne de pêche
c'est le plus gros talent juillet et
pélagiques experts palangrier d'heskey
attrapé du thon et l'espadon c'est le
plus gros de france donc c'est une
exploitation qui n'est pas où il n'y a
pas trop de repères il va falloir
défricher le la voix mais ça déjà fait
plusieurs fois et ça ça ne me fait pas
peur
un petit peu quand même mais ça me plaît
finie la romance bientôt l'action
tarzan donnent l'exemple
tarzan c'est le surnom de bernard le
capitaine cody
son équipage moitié français moitié
malgache connaît bien la palangre à
l'exception de philippe le second guère
habitués à ces études n'ont pas du tout
avant je naviguais
loctudy au chalut ce moment des
chalutiers de 20 matchs et ont travaillé
essentiellement super lent et c'est
d'angleterre
bah j'ai eu une opportunité de
faire un remplacement ici et donc parce
que
mais ce compris le jeu remplace le
second qui sait plus si c'est fait
mordre la main par un requin chaque soir
une ligne interminable du lys dans
l'océan 100 km 100 km qui déroule entre
les mains des marins c'est le filage
toutes les dix secondes un hameçon à
plate et passe par dessus bord deux
mille fois par nuit
avec à chaque fois de drôles de
bâtonnets luminescents
au bout de chaque âme son ami à kalma
les calmars vivent les calmars vivant
attirés par cette cette lumière
ça fait comme
une balise dans la mer
la nuit ça fait quand même un sentier
lumineux vont venir
nager autour de ça les espadons vont
être attirés par les calmars vivants
vont les tuer avec leur le rostre et
vont revenir ensuite mangé les calmars
mort qui restent et au milieu des
calmars mort mais il y en a qui ont un
hameçon dedans et c'est voilà c'est en
gros le principe de
comment est la part des poissons
principalement des espadons
les nuits sont courtes sur le palangrier
hier soir le filage s'est achevée vers
minuit
en cas de casse il peut durer jusqu'à
deux heures du matin
et à 5h quoi qu'il arrive
tout le monde doit être sur le pont
non
[Musique]
dès qu'ils ont retrouvé le début de
ligne grâce à une bouée et maîtrise les
hommes commencent à remonter les
hameçons un parent sans perdre de temps
jusqu'à ce qu'un cris retentissent
ouah ça
je te stable
et hélas 4
première prise
les espagnols ont boudé la ligne mais
lettons ont dévoré les clameurs de
groton dangereux quand on les laisse en
vie
même si l'on n'a pas spécialement pour
l'espadon et même si l'on file la ligne
de nuit pendant sa période de chasse
on ne sait jamais quel type de poisson
viendra mordre à l'hameçon
ça
[Musique]
enfin en voilà un majestueux
bien que les rentes et par les heures de
combat au bout de la ligne
[Musique]
si jacques et les marins préfère
attraper des espadons c'est surtout
parce qu'il se négocie beaucoup plus
cher que les autres poissons aux
environs de 7 euros le kilo le double
des tombes
délesté de ses parures le poisson
mythique ne ressemble plus à grand chose
roi nu
[Musique]
mais à la chair délicate qu'il faut
s'astreindre à garder intact
ce matin-là damien le second mécanicien
venait d'aider les matelots du pont
moi personnellement je préfère
travailler temps
mais c'est plus facile
parce que là la faut travailler avec le
couteau faut bien gratter ça pour un
boulot assez propre c'est pas évident
faut pas abîmer la chair
mais un ou deux poissons ans messieurs
faire un tour en machine on regarde
tout va bien
je vais l'aider sur le pont ramasser
quelques leaders tiré sur le poisson
fait un petit peu de tourner un peu
polyvalent
[Musique]
une dizaine d'espadon durant cette
première journée plus de 900 kg de
poissons en tout insuffisant pour un tel
bateau qui doit tenter de ramener plus
de 50 tonnes durant sa campagne
décidément la silhouette d'hemingway
cesse donc place à la réalité donc à la
rentabilité
[Musique]
je pense qu'on repêche halal online
comme ça les sentiments que l'on peut
éprouver pour la nature son bout d'un
moment atténué par exemple le livre le
vieil homme et la mer qui décrit bien
justement le le combat du vieil homme
contre ce gros poisson qui lui parle
mais c'est parce que c'est le poisson de
sa vie c'est le sait moi j'ai déjà eu
par rapport à des poissons des des
sentiments bizarres ou quand on reste
sur une canne ou sur un fil à la main
pendant des heures seul face à un
poisson là effectivement des certaines
pensées peuvent venir à l'esprit mais
quand on est sur un bateau avec équipage
une autre dynamique
voir et il n'empêche entre jacquet
l'espadon plane comme une obsession
et comme toutes les obsessions elle
remonte à l'enfance
allez jean laborde
et elle a pris forme lorsqu'il a tout
bonnement inventé ce type de pêche à la
réunion il y à une quinzaine d'années
[Musique]
je me suis à le premier espace que j'ai
attrapé ça a été vraiment on l'a regardé
et on l'a pris en photo
c'était un aboutissement
quelque part et et la première tranche
des spas donc j'ai mangé à la réunion je
m'en souviens encore c'était quelque
chose
ça y est j'avais mis le doigt sur un
territoire inconnu
flash back et nous voilà à la réunion
avant le départ dalla longa
retour sur la vie aventureuse d'un
pêcheur émérite tombé dans la potion
marine dès la prime enfance ballotté
entre la réunion et l'île maurice
on m'appelait petit jacques parce que
j'étais j'étais petit je suis toujours
petit et un jour un pêcheur avait une
très belle expression pour parler de moi
il avait frôlé mauricien sa despedida il
ya au moins 20 sur les pieds ça veut
dire que cet enfant a des des algues qui
poussent sous ses pieds
j'avais trouvé ça assez simple dans une
autre vie jacques fut capitaine dans la
marine marchande à l'époque où il
fallait samarie un cocotier pour
décharger les caboteurs puis guide de
pêche au gros
il passe alors son temps dans les ports
des cinq continents à traquer les
techniques de pêche les plus insensés
un jour ils ramènent de floride la
manière de pêcher à la longue line
il décide alors de tenter l'aventuré
tout seul non loin des côtes
réunionnaises
avec ce type de bateau 1,12 m totalement
transformé par ses soins
malgré les sourires narquois des vieux
pêcheur
je pense que jacques il aime bien un peu
les paris comme ça et effectivement
peut-être que c'était osé et puis à
l'époque on disait qu'il avait pas de
poisson dans cette région là je pense
que le fait d'amener une technique
nouvelle
ça a permis de se rendre compte qu'il y
avait quand même une ressource et
qu'après tout la pêcherie réunionnaise
ciblant l'espadon a pu se développer
avec c'est grâce à cette technique là
aujourd'hui une trentaine de bateaux
ramène plus de 1000 tonnes de ce poisson
chaque année un secteur devenu
primordial pour l'économie locale
il est beau il est beau david guiot
marconnet cela sur le bout des doigts
mais ça c'est déjà un beau bestiaux
il y vient de boucler sa thèse sur
l'espadon mais ce qui passionne le jeune
scientifique ce sont surtout les
mystères cachés de cet animal mythique
de
trois ans là et la lune en fait c'est
plutôt lune montante et un grand
chasseur capable d'atteindre les 130
kilomètres à l'heure aussi à l'aise en
surface que dans les ténèbres des
grandes profondeurs en beauté une
journée
l'espadon en fait utilise ses gros yeux
pour justement repérer ses proies et il
a un système en plus de 2 contre-courant
de la circulation sanguine qui lui
permet de garder son cerveau et ses yeux
toujours au chaud avec un système qu'on
appelle le réseau leur était mirabile le
réseau merveilleux qui permet en fait à
aussant
de rester oxygénée et chaud au niveau
des yeux et du cerveau donc pendant la
chasse
retour au large sur à la longue
direction toujours plus au sud dans une
mer qui forci
pour peu que l'on sache l'espagne on vit
dans les eaux chaudes et se nourrit dans
les eaux froides
reste à trouver les zones de rencontre
entre ces deux courants
et vous
on va serrer
il ya beaucoup d'échangés d'informations
et on se base sur certaines approbations
c'est tout le monde le dit pas là ne dit
pas la vérité pour qu'elles ont séparés
je pense que lorsqu'on est loin comme ça
et que on est juste deux ou trois
bateaux c'est quand même intéressant que
l'information
fiables soient échangés sinon ça
la mer est grande le poisson est à tout
le monde
le pélagique
ce que
ce que 20 pêche il
le lac à l'autre sur le pont maître
jacques vient enseigner à philippe
commander snap et comment décrocher des
poudres ligne
à toi que la ligne par sur l'arrière
or pour la ramener sur l'avant
en arriérés
après
mal aux articulations à
pas l'habitude de répéter tout le temps
bon ça
c'est banos a débuté sa vie de matelot
par la pêche à la crevette sur la côte
ouest de madagascar
non
- physique mais moins payant aussi
c'est bannu est certainement le meilleur
vire ou du moins le plus rapide
le veer heures celui qui laisse glisser
la ligne entre ses doigts
devinant à la tension du film si cela a
mordu ou pas
départ cros temps c'est aussi celui qui
se trouve aux premières loges pour les
ombres
m'en fous pas le monde et le travail est
toujours le même ce métier me sentir la
ligne c'est le plus difficile des
magasins alors il faut alterner de temps
en temps quelqu'un doit le remplacer car
si j'étais le seul à tirer toute la
ligne je me fatigue j'ai très vite à 4 6
et 11 étaient à l'arrêt
la gagner
moi ce qui m'a poussé à travailler sur
un bateau français ce sont les
conditions
ici les conditions sont meilleures à des
années
ce soit du point de vue du salaire à
sanaa
la vie à bord et des assurances
merci
[Musique]
depuis peu une loi permet aux armateurs
français de recruter des marins
étrangers et de lait payés au salaire de
leur pays d'origine
ceci explique la présence de cinq
malgaches à bord ici ils perçoivent
jusqu'à 750 euros par mois si la pêche
est bonne
beaucoup plus que le salaire de
madagascar
lucien le cuisinier cumule deux tâches
au four et au moulin et sa journée
débute à 3 heures du matin
je travaille aussi sur le pont dès que
j'en ai fini avec la pêche
je retourne en cuisine jusqu'à la fin du
service et je retourne de nouveau sur le
pont du je mange et je vais dormir les
marais dure près de deux mois avec juste
quelques jours d'escale pour débarquer
le poisson les marins ne pourront donc
rentrer chez eux que deux fois par an
comment ça va
vous n'avez pas loin des raisins tous
les mois s'il garde un quart de mon
salaire et le reste selon bobby on est
habitué à être séparés c'est une
situation à laquelle on est habitué à la
famille ils ont que c'est bien un
problème aujourd'hui
brusque montée d'adrénaline
prudence
un requin
damien venu tout et nico
o o
c'est un animal dangereux et quand il
monte sur le pont
là encore plus fou et
il est pris de panique alors il n'est
pas partout il ya la queue qui est
dangereux il balaye tout le monde puis
si on s'approche trop près il peut nous
croquer un bout de doigt ou
un bout de jambon à pied donc
effectivement la marée dernière qui
s'est passé que
le second capitaine s'est fait à manger
deux doigts de la main gauche et
donc depuis on prend énormément de
précautions effectivement rapatriés par
avion de madagascar le second a eu de
justesse la main sauvés par des
chirurgiens
il reviendra à bord dès la prochaine
marée
on va
et aussi
roj le clou de la journée
voilà
ça
plus de 100 kg assurément
lors de cette marée à la longue à pêcher
environ 40 tonnes de poissons mais plus
de ton que des cependant il est trop tôt
pour dire si le pari de jacques albert
va réussir
et si d'autres bateaux réunionnais vont
se lancer dans ce défi au grand large
moi c'est un poisson qui maquille pas
toujours fasciné parce que j'étais
persuadé qu'un navet dans l'océan indien
et j'ai été un des tout premiers en
attraper
deux manières
régulière et et je n'irai pas
industrielle mai
en grosse quantité donc je mets un petit
peu démystifier à mes yeux mais ça reste
toujours ce beau poisson que
ce que l'on voit arriver près du bateau
il a toujours des couleurs magnifiques
et un rostre impressionnant et et une
chair qui est très bonne au smic
ainsi s'achève le récit d'un séjour à
bord d'un palangrier
il continue sa route tout seul dans
l'océan indien
comme un parfum de grandes aventures
dix hommes en haute mer
la recherche d'un poisson sauvage
majestueux et mythique
[Musique]